>> All right, take me through.
>> Okay. So, the first thing I want to say
is, I think it's awesome that you made me do
this quiz. The second thing I want to say is,
in some sense, every single one of them is correct.
>> Yay!
>> But, you put radio buttons down, not check
box buttons, thingys, so I have to pick one. So
let's just go through. Figure out the best line
to wait in. Well, that is a queue, queue which
would make a lot of sense if I were, say, English.
>> Yes, that's right. In fact, you are, in this picture.
>> Oh yeah, great. [LAUGH]
That's the English version of Charles, the one with the top hat. Okay.
>> Yeah, and a cane, too.
>> Yeah, I like it. And a cane, yes, well
that is typically what I do whenever I go to
London. Discovering when to come in for your line, that
is also a queue-learning though a different kind of queue. que-learning.
The third practicing your best bank shot,
although I probably would've said break shot.
>> Ooh, nice.
>> That is also cue-learning.
>> And it's the same spelling.
>> That's the same spelling.
>> That's unfortunate.
>> Well, you pronounce one cue, and you pronounce the other one cue.
>> Yes, well clearly. But, and I spelled them that way too.
>> Yeah, and I know. I know. I can see where the emphasis is. And the
fourth one is evaluating the Bellman equations from
data. That is you take in the states,
the actions, rewards and the next states, and you try to
learn an actual Q function, which is just the letter Q.
So that is Q-learning, and is the only one that is
spelled correctly, and so that is the choice that I would make.
>> Alright, so, just to be clear here. So
this all [LAUGH] the purpose here other than to.
>> Demonstrate your ability to show puns?
>> [LAUGH] Is that is just to
give the definition. So that, so what Q-learning
is going to be doing is it's going to use transitions, that is
to say data, to directly produce the solution to those Q equations.